bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi io sono pochi genio di sei ore di
seagate delta un reddito non possiamo
fare un episodio su pende da un red
perché valere uscito niente di nuovo ma
la modalità arena di questo gioco
potrebbe darci delle soddisfazioni è la
madonna che cacchio è un film bellissimo
round 1 2 3 4 al 10 va bene io sono e
vabbè non mi ricordo come si già aspetta
four khawatmi loro che ti spacco tutto
allora non ove non mi ricordo i tasti
quindi un attimino che dovevo rientrare
da questo mi paro questo colpisco quello
la lancio è come non ricordare questo è
un calcione
e poi non mi riconoscevo premere per per
fare le mostre speciali probabile 21 dos
tres i 4 ass
eca mons questo porca [ __ ] non è fare
i ragazzi questo è il classico gioco che
gioca a vederlo sembra facile ma non ne
faccio perché questi qua se sì cosa
stronzi euro dico ma poi c'è c'è nel
senso le balle varie ondate sono divise
cioè nel senso mm il recupero la vita
fra non data e l'altro corretto ma
perché se no ho già perso della vita già
sono alla mercè qualcuno vivo si 1 e 2
let's get no ancora un altro porco
demonio bam nell'occhio tutto a posto
ragazzi è a welkom plate l'esc ok a
resettando la vita e non ha resettato il
lo show le modalità segnali manca un
cazzo barba mi ha resettato sto dicendo
la vita ma non
le speciali nelle mani le mosse speciali
quindi meno male almeno posso
sbizzarrirmi right now non ho più armi
armin jacques weber il pericolo che si
ischia non mi ricordo come si usa
formula ok e non schiaccia il tasto 1 va
bene vediamo si rialzano lizzy sicuro
perfetto let's go
ho fatto un danno considerevole perché
pensavo pensavo peggio
qua lancio spa le rotte b che posso
farlo nas normale ragazzi normali se di
recente la vita non è male per adesso
tutto gestibile tutto gestibile poi non
so fino a che punto la random number
four è uno solo a nokia per uno e uno
solo da te pensavo fosse uno solo ma mi
sbaglio
questi sono quelli vestiti bene qua ogni
ondata al suo tema adesso questo non mi
ricordo bene che il tema è ma vabbè chi
vola
ok ok ok dovrebbero essere morti
teoricamente non ne sono sicuro
però credo di sì mamma in the head
le scrivo ho i soldi le mazzetta di
soldi in faccia perfetto tira teme
neanche a me quelle una banca 1 browser
face minchia non gli affari non hai
fregato nulla
porca vacca resistito fortissimo lo zio
non gliene è fregato nulla del mio colpo
non chucu o come cazzo ti chiami la
madonna non gliene frega nulla
porca [ __ ] regala pazzesco dei gay da
gamba ok ora è mori però quanto tempo
madonna ragazzi pazzesco e ho finito le
armi
sai questo potrebbe essere un problema
non so più come colpirlo così cazzottoni
in bocca non ho altro modo riuscirlo gli
es av finito non hai o più armi c'è
veramente non potevo fare altro cazzotti
da face che non ci aveva più la face ma
va bene va bene 8.000 messo fano fino
adesso mambo fa devo dare una mano agli
amici se non il primo picchiato o
picchiato un mio amico l'unica roba che
non dovevo fare l'ho fatta
l'hack è male micali scelte sono
incredibili madonna ma che sono ste cose
i miei amici muoiono subito il tempo
zero non è servito a niente
i miei amici fanno schifo c'era
veramente non è servito al sono morti
tutti
porca vacca questa ragazza in modo
sicuro sono troppe armi anche a [ __ ]
hanno troppe armi affilate sti affari
costano diffici sino a schivare ok non
ho più armi non ho più armi e sono in
duemila credo che cacchio faccio
purtroppo ho fatto l'unica cosa che
potevo fare lega calcio in the face à
volendo li posso spingere nelle trappole
credo non lo so vediamo vediamo se
riesco a lla che male non credo gliene
freghi niente delle trappole proprio non
le vedo neanche una pagaia è fortissima
la pagaia aiuto uso qua perché se non ce
la farò mai più veramente ragazzetti ok
ok io schiaffati un botto per terra
aprendo le loro armi se riesco dai arma
per favore si mischiano picchiato a caso
non va dato niente normale non mai
mollato l'arma manco per sbaglio ho
lanciato la accetta per niente madonna
con uno preso danno come non ho preso un
anno dove andata a cielo lanciata già
una spada non so come ma devo sfruttare
fino alla fine sua spada se non perso ok
madonna rega non so come ho fatto a
farsa parte ve lo giuro perché erano
veramente tanti
fondata numero sei lì a un cacchio c'è
stavolta a stavolta minchia veramente
solo lui cometa vita c'è un pugile a
vediamo se riusciamo a pugni e basta
calci in bocca ai anche male eh vabbè
fortissimo scusatemi c'è il fuoco di
lazio non so se ti conviene
no no come la zero cosa
a sto punto raga provava la volete
infinito per vedere che cosa succede ma
c'è ma giusto perché non mi va di di
farle tutte c'è una cappa che possono
accogliere con 1400 e 1.000 punti ok
e vabbè mi che cazzo sei o che cazzo
succede non ora non oro come lo prendo
loro giorno loro lo prendo ammazzando la
gente ho capito ma quello che uso queste
cose bertero che scroll che è male ma
domanda lei comunque veramente ci vuole
la scritta nostro gioco deve schivare
manco in dark souls devo riuscire a
sopravvivere fino a che non riesco a
prendere un arma decente madonna che
male non va preso ma li potete colpire
tra di voi tipo posso fare colpire
quello coraggio gli altri amici sono
messi
oddio cos'è santo gesù
ok mi sembra un po eccessivo che c'è uno
di minecraft questo maori
madonna è mi ha fatto male perché
impossibile cioè veramente gestire tutto
assurdo ok shock mail pronto meno male
perché non sapevo da che parte farmi 3 2
1 ho fatto qualche minimo di danno l'ho
fatto solo non l'ho fatto come modalità
e un pelo too much raga secondo me poi
vabbè fate voi
d'accordo va bene di ai ragazzi di fare
quindi l'ultima e vedere che succede con
l'arrivo manca compra minar ma manco per
sbaglio ci è impossibile
mi serve un arma una quella libertà è la
brava bravi che hanno incrociato haven e
john giorno questo mi sono un po
eccessivo
fuori madonna quanto fate male mi
chiamava
ho bisogno di camomilla
veramente ho bisogno di tante camillo
però evidenti e vegeta ragazzi cosa vi
piace fatemi sapere se volete che lo
continui perché c'è un po di roba qua e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]